her we have the all-time champion in
English Steve goblins have in the blue
corner we have his challenger Benny the
Irish polygon monsters let's get ready
to rumble like an official can I go get
my weapons now listen Benny before we
get going oh yeah I know I heard a rumor
that in fact you travel a lot because
you're you're a fugitive from some
jealous husband is that true would you
like to comment on that yes but that was
before the sex change so I thought I
don't want to get into that these are
hard feelings from the past and I don't
want to take that up okay it's cuttings
and mitosis all right
the other thing I heard was that your
Irish accent is a fake but actually you
have a New York accent and you're no no
not New York I'm from North Carolina
okay yeah I actually wrote a blog post
about this a year ago I and I did
genuinely I I said I this has all been
affect the Irish accents been a fake I
faked all my videos and it was my April
Fool's joke I got a great knife no
because I think your Irish accent is a
bit extreme to be here I should I should
have more top of the morning to you is
thrown in just good measure yeah
right listen I want to say first of all
that I was tremendously impressed with
your whole the whole project the skype
me maybe project and I'll tell you a
couple of reasons why first of all the
idea and then second of all to get
everyone to do it and to collect all
those videos and to put it all together
is just an amazing task that you're a
one-man PR band I have to make sure
everyone was happy as well because as
you know those Thursday ffunny a few
tweaks or with several people you know
the first draft was just ours what
really impressed me too was you sent me
the script and I had some concerns with
some of the wording and so forth and you
said y'all go ahead change it you know I
was really good at it and he does why
this wasn't
it's just me and my idea for the project
and when the worked and you know and
it's not not just changing some of the
barracks that you suggested and I I sang
the lyrics myself that you personally
sent me but you know a few other people
had a few other suggestions for the
video and so on and that that was what I
wanted I want my actually wanted
feedback I wanted this to be a
collaborative I mean I was going to do
all the video editing but ultimately
like Suzanna helped me with the lyrics
and a couple of other people happy with
the storyline and it worked out really
well and like I got inspired to do this
because we're during the summer when I
met up with Moses mcCormick
the video that the two of us did
together was so well-received
everyone loved us because it was
something different you know it was Tea
Party God's doing something like in the
mall trying to level up as he calls us
and that's what I wanted to do I wanted
to kind of go you know fear off the
normal interview style and have us do
something fun together now let me ask
you the $64,000 question it's very easy
to get the various polyglots and it's
not just the however many we were in
that film or in that video there's lots
of polyglots on the internet that's one
of the things that we've we've
discovered because of the various things
that we're doing so there probably
hundreds of polygons how do you get
there are other hundreds of thousands of
millions of people who at some level say
I would like to learn X Y Zed language
how do you actually get them to commit
themselves and to stay the course and to
achieve success to me beyond any other
teaching problem you know subjunctive
feminine yen or whatever that's the core
issue and you are probably the one man
band out there promoting more
effectively than anyone else but but are
you reaching those people and and how do
you reach those people
separate to the Skype me video one thing
which I'm very proud of the reaction
I've been telling is the videos up in
uploading of me trying to speak Arabic
what is very very different people have
told me on what I hope other polyglots
expand and I know they've seen a couple
of videos like this from other people
but is that you see every stage of every
step of the way you could see my very
very first time ever speaking Arabic on
camera you could see my very first time
trying to record a conversation and the
point is you could see me struggle you
could see me sweat you can see me look
like an idiot you can see that you know
my you can see my brain melting
basically as I'm trying to think of what
to say and this inspired a lot of
monocots and um one thing is a lot a lot
of videos they discuss methods and so on
and that's all great you know should we
learn the subjunctive should we learn
grammar these are all very important
questions but what I think gets through
to people much more is when you appeal
to their human nature and you show them
it's not the fact that I'm a genius that
I'm just naturally picking this up
because I've got this magic talent that
you but you don't it's because I'm
working hard you could see that I'm
going through struggles and I'm human
being so you can do it too
and you know this is what I have found
effective in getting through to people I
do get a lot of emails every day I get
about 400 emails a day from my blog and
a lot of these are people saying that
I've I've inspired them to learn a
language just through sharing my stories
you know I know I don't talk about
methods so much I do like to talk more
about the confidence side of it and you
know and III agree with the top the tone
of the conversation we all had the other
day that there is no one method and I've
actually many times told people if they
have suggested that they would learn a
language more like you I've referred
them to you and I've said listen my
strategy is not gonna work for you it's
gonna stress you out and it's not
necessary for your goals so question is
though you show yourself struggling you
show that language learning is a lot of
work which we all know it is and we all
get told well you just have a
four languages and then all your effort
is just dismissed
you just have a knack for it yeah I
agree with you I mean it's a lot of work
I mean very few people that I know if
any other than people like you are
willing to put the time and effort into
language learning that I do so you know
I work hard at but then if you show
people this are people prepared to work
that harder you know you know also have
to show them the the Apple you know the
the benefits I don't know it yeah yes
some people are inspired by seeing a
struggle some people may say geez I
wouldn't want to put myself through that
right and that's why at least this year
my strategy has been twofold with both
Mandarin and now with harvick it is
first you see three months where it's
just me learning the language
it's me struggling and it's me admitting
that I'm very frustrated and I'm working
really hard on this and then following
that up is entirely as you call it the
Apple it's all the benefits and I I'm
very very pleased with some of the
videos I made that I managed to go to
this small farming village in China and
I got a kung-fu lesson from a very
well-known master or you know I talked
to all these people on a train or I
interviewed a newscast TV reporter and
you know my level is definitely not
perfect and the people with very very
high standards would be very quick to
criticize my tones I didn't use this
right word but I'm I'm not concerned
about that very much and I say this very
often I am NOT a perfectionist I am more
interested in results even if they're
messy at first and - inspires
monolinguals what can I ask you a couple
of questions first I'm going to ask you
an easy question that I can ask you a
couple of difficult questions all right
the easy question is which are you
finding more difficult it which is more
difficult as a complete newcomer our
bigger Chinese I don't like that
question to know for me that's that's
the difficult question all right because
I my whole philosophy is I am NOT
interested in being pessimist
okay but are you further along after two
months or however long you've been at it
or are you not as far along as you were
in Chinese very high level of Arabic now
is better than at what than my level of
Chinese was when the school in Beijing
graded in my level they reckoned I was
about to be one people are just you know
arguing about that but they were
unbiased they recognized me one I'm
better than that right now now this a
lot of people would very quickly say
okay
therefore Arabic is easier but this is
actually because of a very very
different technique and approached I've
been applying this time that was less
efficient earlier this year
oh can you explain the do different
approaches um what this year I went to
Taiwan I lived in Taiwan for three
months and unfortunately up to that
stage one thing people would always say
when the read my blog is I can't really
learn like you do because you voted a
country and it was presumed that I kind
of felt that you have to go to the
country to learn the language because I
was I was going to the country although
I was doing that because I'm a traveler
now the problem was that Taiwan has a
very very different culture that I was
not used to its and what this meant is I
had two big problems the linguistic
problem of learning Mandarin and they
had the culture problem of integrating
my stuff and getting used to the rules
of social interaction and I felt that
are dealing with these two at the same
time was a very very big challenge which
I did not have to deal with in many
European situations even Hungarian
Hungarian was such a different language
but because they're European I kind of
related them in such a way that I can go
out and I can make conversations with
people but the social rules are so
different in Taiwan so what happened was
I was very stressed out because I didn't
actually have a very good social social
network and that's hung down whereas
here what I decided to do differently
was in Brazil I would be focusing on
learning Arabic for the majority
today the majority of the week and in
once a week I would let my hair down and
I would go as on I party in Portuguese
and whatever and I found that this
completely distressed me because I was
just at my absolute limit and I got to
reach in this limit and I want and then
any time I'd study after a couple of
weeks we would just go in one ear and
out the other
always I'm not like that now so I don't
actually tell them but you do not have
to go abroad to learn language alright
just a couple things here I should say
first of all that I think what you did
in in Taiwan and China is great whether
you were B 1 B 3 C 8 doesn't matter to
me the fact that you would throw
yourself into the language acquire
enough Chinese that you can read some
that you can communicate however well
I'm not for me to judge that's something
you'll always have with you
I think it's tremendous and I made that
comment a number of times whenever the
subject came up with forums and
elsewhere the issue sometimes is you
know the claims versus what to achieve
forget the claims what he did is great
and I think what you do in general is
great in other words not to go to Brazil
and work on your Arabic I mean you're
gonna have I could keep at it you're
gonna have in your little arsenal of
languages and people with whom you can
communicate you know ranging people
ranging from Europeans to are the
average European yes Chinese Arabic and
so forth so that's wonderful
I must say with regard to Taiwan that
having been the time on quite a few
times I find the people that are
actually quite easy to talk to hmm if I
compare them to checks for example in
Eastern Europe you got a picture slots
because some people are very friendly
and some people are very slim early in
Taiwan there are too many snarly people
I found that if I wander in a place to
say a few things in Chinese they're all
over me but I mean that we all have
different experiences the they're much
friendlier you know the issue for me is
that I tend to learn the best of my
languages when I'm out socializing with
people and what you're not doing that in
Brazil right now you're not gonna have
that's true that's true so that's that's
added new challenges for me here I I
have every single day and what's been
the core of me learning Arabic is
speaking it that's always what I focus
on every single day I've had one or two
hours of as spoken essence and it's been
a bit formal so you know it's for me to
be totally honest the last three months
have been very boring mm-hmm I've been
focused on progress and for me it's been
a sacrifice such that for the for the
two months or so that I'm gonna be in
Egypt I can 100% appreciate the culture
of my country without having to have my
head in books for a long time that was
for me the kind of you know deal with
the language first and then it breaks
the culture later but you know what I
think that what you have stumbled upon
here is an excellent way to learn a
language go to someplace you really like
where the weather is nice you have a
good you know lots of friends and study
whatever long as you want
yeah in other words you don't have to go
to the country you know if you are gonna
study Russian don't go to st. Petersburg
in the middle of winter you know go to
Brazil where the Sun shines anyway I'm
just joking but I think the point you're
making is that the and I think we're in
what you said earlier on is the method
doesn't really matter my god as you know
I have a different approach like my
approach to check was basically just to
learn here I didn't have the luxury to
charge off to to Prague and I kind of
feel that if I have a certain level of
the language as you now feel with Arabic
going in that I'm better able to take
advantage of being in the country
because right shreddy understand I could
communicate and so forth and I also did
put up a few videos of myself struggling
after say six months and nine months
it's over hmm but I think the big thing
is is the whole motivation I think the
big thing that you bring to language
learning is motivation the enthusiasm
with which you attack all these
languages sure there's a bit of fire and
brimstone and you know little of
bushfires here and there but it doesn't
matter I think the fact that you have
attracted so many people to your blog
and all of those people are interested
in language right there they're not
there because they want to discuss you
know the politics of Ireland Rennie
they're there because they're interested
in language Ernie you brought them there
you motivate them I think that's a
tremendous achievement if there were an
award for the language learning promoter
of the year you know you would get it
and I think that you're doing the job of
a lot of language teachers because if
I've always felt and this was my own
experience when I had a teacher like I
had French in school much like you have
German I think it was it wasn't until I
had a professor at university who really
turned down the French that turned me on
learning it and then the other language
is soap and so on so the big deal is to
turn the learner on that is more
important than whether you speak from
day one or not from day one all of that
absolutely how do you turn the learner
on and I think you're probably I mean
Moses right up there as well and all of
the other public glass the rest of us
are a more kind of demure bunch you know
but you are more flamboyant and and
Moses in his folksy way I think both of
you have been tremendous sources of
inspiration so I I think we can kind of
call it there I just I wanted to have a
chat with you because again I wanted to
say how much I admire respect what you
did on that video I don't know what are
we at 80 or 90 thousand yeah definitely
over 80,000 done it stood bran right so
you know and keep it up and keep turning
people on and people will find their own
way and they'll pick their
I mean Luka likes to translate them you
know Richard does other stuff at Moses
as yeah yeah it's not it's not about the
method it is your motivation and people
do things the opposite of me and you
know I've talked to people with very
different strategies to me and it's not
about you must follow these you know
magic steps to learn the language if you
are passionate about it then that's
going to make all the difference you
know if you're passionate about what
you're doing then do that you're love
reading read as much as possible and you
know my case I love speaking so I'm
going to speak as much as possible and
investigate you know what watch videos
from several people really several
different blogs and decide for yourself
and you can see what works for you what
you know maybe someone's personality is
suited better to yours
and and I
that's why it's great that there are so
many of us and I would definitely not
want to be doing this alone because that
would be much much worse but my concern
is are we getting out of the polyglot
get home or are we just attracting
like-minded people and I think that's
where perhaps you have broken through
because I think you do appeal to a lot
of what you called mono glass for people
who are hesitant who don't have the
confidence and I always say this until
you have actually transformed yourself
into a confident speaker of another
language you don't know what it's like
and therefore the first new language you
learn in some ways is the most difficult
and and you're you're encouraging people
to get out by the way before we need can
I any sort of hot news that you're gonna
be able to devote here like your next
challenge after Arabic or is there
anything that we can pass on that no one
else knows about um I'm probably gonna
write this in the blog maybe in a few
days but I don't you don't have to
develop it but I can tell people they're
they already kind of know this bunch
they will definitely find me and at the
polygon conference in Budapest in May
okay well good I don't know if we're
gonna be able to make it there because I
got other commitments but that sounds
funny to get together yeah if you make
it I hope you do otherwise I will be
heading across the pond sometime next
year and I hope I run into you okay
Benny thank you very much for doing this
and keep up all right hey thanks for the
kind words stay by yourself here you're
motivating a lot of people yourself
though don't sell yourself short I'm not
either all right okay thank you very
alright Garcia